[Music]
foreign
the British are experiencing a sharp
epitech in cyber attacks
the Thames barrier failed
causing the worst floods in the capital
for over a century
The Operators think someone got it
we've been tracking the suspect
we think it's connected to a terrorist
plot
patient recognition identifies him as
Gabriel's Lodge
I should call the police yeah yeah you
should
n't for five years and getting married
you tell him everything
[Music]
[Applause]
the plans are here the attack is over
already
no that was a warning until somebody
claims responsibility it's not over and
you just friend after what you did to
him
if you hit me you wouldn't be wrong
changed you think we can change
[Music]
to get a grip of this Allison I need
you guys more than you do
you're going to slow the risk
State and you'll get killed
I know they're planning an attack and
you just want me to run what do you take
me for
foreign
[Music]